Hello there!
In the last video, we outlined the history
of the Transformer.
I hope that now that you know about the Transformer’s
success and proliferation, you now are curious
enough to see how it works!
Because in this video, Ms. Coffee Bean will
help me briefly explain the Transformer architecture.
We will explain the Transformers for sequence
to sequence modelling, that we employ in machine
translation for example.
We remember that Recurrent Neural Networks,
the precursors of the transformers, use to
process the text sequentially, word AFTER
word.
They produce a vector from a whole sequence,
hoping to capture the meaning of the whole
sentence.
This is of course problematic with long and
complicated sentences.
Then from this vector, another RNN block is
decoding to the target sequence, in this case,
it is decoding to the translation of the sentence.
So one part here in green, we can call from
now on the encoder, and the one in orange
red, is the decoder.
But what is it that Transformers do differently?
The key with the transformers, is that while
RNNs process input piece AFTER piece, the
Transformer processes the whole sequence at
ONCE.
And with parallelization comes a lot of the
power of the Transformer.
Now we know what is done, but not how it is
done.
It is now time to get into the details of
the Transformer architecture.
Usually, the Transformer encoder is actually
a stack of encoders in layers.
Stacking the encoders, enabled us to process
the sequence not only once, but a couple of
times.
And what we do for the encoder, we also do
for the decoder.
The idea behind stacking is to be able to
capture raw properties of the sentence first,
moving to more elaborate properties.
To exemplify: It has been shown that these
layers of the Transformer architecture are
discovering the NLP pipeline: the first layers
focus on identifying part-of-speech tags,
followed by constituents, dependencies, semantic
roles and coreference.
And of course, this structure is a little
fuzzier in reality, but it is there!
Now let us dissect one of these transformer
encoder layers.
All encoder layers are built of the same kind
of blocks: The self-attention layer that processes
the input and transmits it to a “normal”
feed forward neural network.
We will explain self-attention shortly.
After we process the input through a couple
of these encoders, we are ready to construct
a sequence, which should be in this example
the translation of the input after we pass
it through the decoder.
For the decoder, we have the same two blocks
as for the encoder with a special encoder-decoder
attention layer in the middle.
So far, we listed the order of the layers
that form the transformer blocks.
Now for explaining what these layers do exactly,
it is vector/tensor-flow time!
We say vectors, because of course, our network
does not look at the text itself,
but rather at a vector representation of this
text.
These vectors are pre-computed with a word
embedding method of our choice.
And these vectors, go into the self-attention
layer.
Self-attention is very similar to attention,
which we remember computes an importance score
for each word vector.
So in attention, if we want to translate this
sentence, attention computes importance between
two different sequences and tells us that
for translating “rabbit” to “Hase”,
we might want to focus to both “rabbit”
and “it”, because they both refer to the
same entity.
This kind of attention we want to use in the
decoder between encoder layers and decoder
layers.
Self-attention is good at modelling dependencies
between different parts of the sequence.
For example to understand dependencies between
words in a sentence.
These might be syntactic dependencies or coreference,
like in this example here.
Self-attention computes importance scores
between words of the same sequence.
And the best thing about Transformers is the
multi-head attention.
Where the attention we know, is not computed
once, as there is no single attention pattern
that helps in some cases, but there could
be multiple attentions computed at the same
time, called attention heads.
In this way, instead of one pattern, we have
7, 9, or 12 or as many attention heads as
we want and these are regarded at the same
time!
Now back to our figure here.
After the self-attention layer computed on
the input its output vectors, taking into
account the dependencies of words between
each other, it passes its vectors on to simple,
feed forward neural layers; these sending
the processed output further to the next encoder
layer formed after the same encoder blueprint.
We have to stop here shortly and observe how
each word flows on it’s own path and all
these computations per path can be done in
parallel, in contrast to recurrent neural
networks, where one word has to wait for the
output from the previous word.
This parallelization speeds up training considerably,
this is why Transformers can be trained relatively
quickly on huge amounts of text.
But if everything here has it’s own path
looking at the neighbors only through self-attention,
there is yet no way to model word order!
What to do now??
Well, researchers have a very simple solution
for this problem.
They take every input vector and add a positional
encoding vector, meaning that they add to
each word representation a so-to-say unique
ID, corresponding to the position in the sentence!
Done!
This is how the network knows the word order
and it knows if it is at the beginning, middle
or at the end of the sentence.
That was easy…!
One more thing left to mention here: The output
of each layer, here the input,
is added to the output of the next sublayer.
This is called a residual connection and enables
better flow of information through the network,
so that information is not lost by one layer
without a chance for the next layer to recover
it.
And what was shown here for the first layer,
happens in every layer.
Now we have the stage set for explaining how
this monster architecture delivers an output:
Because here is where the magic in the decoder
happens: The decoder has the same structure
as the encoder with the only difference, that
it has an encoder-decoder attention layer
in the middle.
So the decoder, processes the vectors like
the encoder, but also computes attention between
the decoder vectors and the output of the
first encoder.
This helps the decoder to focus on the appropriate
input parts.
And now for the final output computation,
the very last layer of the network is the
softmax layer, which assigns for each word
in the vocabulary a probability and all these
probabilities sum up to 1.
For visualization purposes, we listed only
3 words of a vocabulary that for English would
consist of tens of thousands of words.
The biggest probability here would be ideally
“ich”, as it translates to German the
English “I”.
The process repeats itself for the next position
of the word, which is the second word and
so on, until the model predicts with highest
probability the stop word, where the sentence
reached its end.
This is what a trained model should be able
to give us.
Reasonable probabilities over this vocabulary.
At training time we have first a model unable
to predict reasonable probabilities, so we
teach it.
We run it on text, these could be sentences
and their translation, where we know what
the next word should be.
And interestingly, we do not predict the next
word necessarily, because we can also train
to predict a randomly masked word and try
to predict it with the softmax.
This is called masked word prediction.
If the model did not perform well, since it
“thought”...
Do neural networks think? ...that “Katze”,
meaning cat was the most probable word in
this case, since we
know that the correct word should be “bin”,
we penalize the model and update it through
backpropagation, until it does reasonably
well in training.
And if you are not very much excited yet,
this is the best part about Transformers:
They train very easily with self-supervision,
meaning that they do not necessarily need
annotated training data to be able to capture
human language.
Because Transformers are trained to predict
randomly masked words, if we want to use them
for text completion or if we want the Transformers
to write novels, all they need is text lying
around on Wikipedia and they can already start
training!
Or even better, we can pre-train them to predict
masked words on large corpora containing news
articles and we can train them further (called
fine-tuning) on less data for other tasks
like sentiment classification, because only
by pre-training to predict words on the news
articles, the Transformer learned something
about sentiment classification already!
How to test if a model trained on task A,
has also implicitly learned how to model task
B, we have already explained in the video
linked right now!
Thanks for watching, do not forget to hit
the like and subscribe buttons, and see you
next time!